marie de rabutin chantal marquise de
sévigné est le seul auteur classique
français dont l'oeuvre souhaite
uniquement composé de lettres
l'histoire est connue sa fille françoise
épouse en 1669 le compte de grignan peu
après nommé lieutenant général en
provence le couple quitte paris et
commence alors entre la mère et la fille
une correspondance qui s'étend sur un
quart de siècle la marquise de sévigné
aurait composé un millier de lettres
pour les trois-quarts adressée à sa
fille c'est un véritable journal de son
époque qu à son insu sans doute la
marquise de sévigné expédie deux fois
par semaine à sa fille la cour de louis
xiv les événements petits ou grands les
intrigues l'air du temps elle les met en
scène avec un sens remarquable de
l'effet et du style aux éditions mango
paraît à destination des jeunes lecteurs
une sélection d'une vingtaine de ces
courriers illustrés par des artistes
contemporains
voici comment madame de sévigné décrite
à sa fille les bienfaits de la douche
un beau jour du printemps 1676 j'ai
commencé aujourd'hui la douche c'est une
assez bonne répétition du purgatoire
on est tous tenus dans un petit lieu
sous terre où l'on trouve un tuyau de
cette eau chaude qu'une femme vous fait
aller où vous voulez cet état où l'on
conserve à peine une feuille de figuier
pour tout habilement est une chose assez
humiliante
représentez-vous un jet d'eau contre
quelques unes de vos pauvres partie on
s'attache aux jointures qui ont été
affligées mais quand on vient à la nuque
du coup c'est une sorte de feu et de
surprises qui ne se peut comprendre
cependant c'est là le noeud de la faire
il faut tout souffrir et l'on souffre
tout et l'on n'est point brûlé et on se
met ensuite dans un lit chaud où l'on
suit abondamment et voilà ce qui guérit